Wow!
Hello, everybody!
Whoa!
Give me a sec.
We're not watching.
Whoa, look!
It's Blade!
Oh, my God!
I forgot it!
All of our plays!
Blade!
Hello, everyone!
Hello!
Yes, if you guys didn't know, a huge shout-out to Marvel Rivals Devs for sponsoring today's stream.
Yes, I have early access to season 3.5 of Marvel Rivals, which means they finally released Blade!
Yes, he's finally freed!
They've teased Blade for, like, three seasons, and now he's finally here.
I like how every time... Sorry, I'm lying.
Every time, they were like, oh, new character!
They're like, is it Blade?
And then it's not Blade, and you see him, like, in random areas of the map.
In different parts of the map, and you're just like, someone free him, please!
Like, first he was caged, then he was sleeping, and then he disappeared!
Where is he?
But finally, he's... Yeah, finally, he's no longer Eepie!
Yeah!
But yes, he's very excited.
Like I said, a huge shout-out to the Marvel Rivals Dev Team for reaching out to me, for it to participate in the early access season 3.5.
There's a lot of new updates coming in, not just Blade.
Apparently, there's a lot of changes, a lot of reworks, and stuff like that.
Some really good skins coming out for those who are into that, too.
Yeah, it only took three seasons to tie the rope.
What else is there?
Oh yeah, for those who don't know, the newest season will release on August 8th, and Marvel Rivals is free to play!
So, you can check out Marvel Rivals right now, and download it with the link pinned in the chat, or like on the panel, too.
So anyway, let's watch Blade and see what he does.
I did like... I'll do... I'll spoil it a little bit.
I did check out a little bit of Blade before, just to like test things out.
His kit is weird.
His... I'm not... I don't want to say weird.
His kit is unique, in a way where you can melee or not melee.
So, like, you can use a gun or not melee, which is pretty interesting, because I don't think we have a character that can swap between the two.
Uh, but yeah, let's watch the trailer real quick.
There he is!
There's Blade!
Yeah, so you can see him melee here.
And then he can... See, he has a gun.
So it's like, they're too far.
I'll just shoot him, I guess.
Yeah, he's a hybrid.
Yeah.
And he... Since he is a vampire, he has lifesteal.
So you can see down there below.
Yeah.
You already see that he has lifesteal.
His all is crazy, though.
Like, I'm trying to figure out, like, how do you counter that?
Like... I'm wondering, like, does it stop after you, when you die?
Like...
Yeah.
Yeah, so he has lifesteal, and he actually has an ability where he can slow people down, too.
So it's... It's, uh...
Yeah, yeah, it's very interesting.
You can swap between the two, which I found out.
But anyway, um, other than that, let's watch the... The dev thing.
We'll go through this one really quick, because, um, there's only one thing that I'm interested in, and it is...
Um... Where is it?
Sorry, Blade.
We already saw about you.
It's... This.
So...
There's new team-ups and everything.
The fact... By the way, they finally buffed Adam.
Like, they actually gave him legs.
Like...
They decided not to... Not to break his knees today... For, like, this... To the new season.
It's actually crazy.
I was like, oh my god!
They actually... They gave him... They gave him legs again.
And... Yeah, they're like, you know what?
We'll let you walk this season.
Um...
He can actually walk this season.
So, this is very interesting.
This team-up...
To be fair, um...
I'm not complaining, because I'm a Luna main.
But it's so funny that, like, they give Luna everything.
I...
The neighbor's like...
This is the greed they talk about in the Bible.
I feel like every season, Luna always gets, like, an extra buff.
And I'm like...
I don't...
I'm not complaining.
I was like, yes!
I'm so hungry!
Oh my...
It's like, please!
I'm so hungry!
And then you're like...
Wait, Luna, didn't you get buff?
It's like, I'm so...
Hungry!
I take this.
Yeah, so for those who don't know...
Luna's new team-up with Adam...
Is, uh...
Is that when she...
She has a link where if she links to someone else, she gets lifesteal.
So, like, basically, she's, again, a lot stronger to survive dive now.
And then I thought this was, like, really funny.
Because Loki already got nerfed.
They, like, broke Loki's shins, like, last season or, like, this season.
And then they're like, they're like, you know what?
Don't worry, we can rebuild you.
So this is his new team-up where...
His new buff where...
This is bigger.
The lamp is bigger.
And it does...
It boosts every stat.
If you're...
If you're in the lamp, you get a boost of all your stats.
So you get damage boosts and everything.
If you're in the lamp.
So, um, so they're like...
So they, like, they, like, you know what?
We'll fix you.
And this one is crazy.
Groot's thing...
Groot's walls can heal you now.
That's crazy.
I could literally build a house around us and we'll be safe.
I'll be like, don't worry, child.
I'll keep you safe.
They're like, don't worry, child.
I'll keep you safe in my home.
Um, but Arbus has a new team-up.
I don't really understand this one.
Um, Star-Lord has, like, a TP thing now.
So he can teleport.
And it doesn't seem like there's a range from what I've seen.
Um, yeah, I can't believe my...
And then Blade has the cloaking thing.
So I feel like a lot of the team-ups are very interesting.
Uh, so there's a new resource rumble.
So these were, like, the things I wanted to focus on.
Because I thought they were pretty...
They did a new...
Oh, yeah, so there's also the land thing.
So I think these were all the things I wanted to look at.
Um, other than that, another thing, they changed competitive.
Where if someone leaves on your team, um, you don't get punished as hard.
So I thought that was an interesting change that they did for competitive.
Anyway, it's time for the real...
Um, the real stream.
Looking at the skins.
Third...
I already bought it just so we can go through everything.
A third person, baby!
So there's Queen's Codex.
Is that Psylocke?
Oh my god.
I've...
Wait, no, that's...
No, that's Widow.
This is...
Um...
Oh my gosh.
Whoa.
Well, I didn't...
I don't know why I went with Psylocke first.
Just because I feel like...
Psylocke gets everything she ever wants.
Psylocke players get...
Oh, yeah, and they have the...
They have the Thing skin, too.
Uh, Thing Venom.
Oh my god.
Monkey.
Oh, wait, that goes hard.
So...
Alright, and then there's the Hella skin.
That's from the...
Uh...
The...
Launcher intro.
I thought this was already released.
I didn't realize it was...
It's releasing, like, in August 8th.
Um...
But...
I like this skin.
I think this is the best Hella skin they have.
Um...
I personally don't like the other Hella skins.
So I think this one's the best one so far.
Oh, there's no game audio.
My bad.
Sorry, guys.
There was nothing to really hear anyway.
Ha ha ha ha!
Yeah, I think this one's...
I think this is the best Hella skin they've had.
Oh, and then there's the Emote.
I believe those are all the newest skins.
I think.
Yeah, these are all the newest skins.
For those who didn't want to...
Who didn't hear this.
All right, but...
Yeah, those are all of them.
And then...
Then there's Blade.
Ooh!
I want to hear Thing!
Okay, I'll let you hear Thing.
Give me a sec.
There you go.
Look at him go.
Rah!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
All right.
Well, now we can look at Blade again.
So...
There's...
Ooh!
Polarity Edge.
Meaning Spire Life and Void.
It makes something that shouldn't exist.
Oh, that's sick.
All right.
I would say...
This is a sick...
Oh my god.
Who the fuck is she?
Blade, I didn't know you...
What?
Damn, Blade.
Okay.
I would say this skin is sick.
But his default is so fucking iconic, though.
Like...
I don't know.
I feel like...
We waited...
I don't know.
We waited so long for him to be in the game.
That, like...
It's...
It's a crime to not have his default on.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
The sentence...
The skin is sick!
But, like...
We waited so long for Blade.
Ha ha ha!
And it's already...
It's so iconic.
Yeah.
It's, like...
So iconic, too.
Um...
But the skins are really cool.
Oh my god.
The hunt is on.
All right.
Here's the MVP.
I want to look at it on.
Default Blade, though.
All right.
What's this?
Oh, this is a...
A newer one.
The World Cutter.
Yeah, we waited...
Not even months.
It's, like...
Like, they've been teasing Blade since Season Zero.
I'm pretty sure.
He's been teased for...
Since Season Zero.
And then, like...
We got baited for, like...
Every Season on...
We're like...
Is it Blade Time?
Is it...
And they're like...
Nope.
Here...
Here's the Fantastic Four.
And then we're like...
Wait.
Is it Blade Time now?
And then...
Nope.
Here's...
Here's Phoenix.
Yeah.
He looks so cool.
Um...
But yeah.
I'll show you guys...
Oh yeah.
What does his Lord icon look like?
Oh...
Wait.
Mmm...
I don't...
I don't know.
I don't feel...
I feel like...
It'd be cooler...
If his Lord icon...
Is...
Yeah.
Bro is sleeping for the longest time...
For him to go outside.
I think it'd be cooler...
If the Blade was...
Sticking out.
Instead of, like...
Covering his face.
Um...
He comes out on August 8th.
By the way, guys.
For those who are wondering...
You'll be able to play...
Blade on...
August 8th.
Everybody.
Alright.
Let's...
Let us...
Go to the practice range now.
Alright.
Now let's check out Blade.
For real.
Yeah.
Or behind his head.
I agree.
I feel like it definitely...
They definitely could have...
Made it a little...
More...
I guess like...
Legible?
For Blade?
But like...
It's still pretty cool.
I think...
I like the non...
Uh...
The non-Lord icon.
More...
Okay.
So...
So like I said...
You can...
That's the headshot damage.
You can do...
Uh...
Gun?
Or...
You can swap to melee.
So...
What was interesting about it was...
There's a dash here.
I think that's the shift.
Yeah.
And then the blue thing is...
Um...
The blue was...
I think it was like...
Less healing.
I believe.
Yeah.
Healing reduction.
It's healing reduction effect.
So there's a healing reduction effect for it.
When you do that.
So it's the shift.
And then...
There's the...
Melee.
Which is just a...
Spin!
And then like I said...
He has like the little...
Yeah.
He has...
Um...
He has hybrid.
Basically.
And then you can...
You have to press E for this.
To get the...
The...
Like the...
Light leech.
Or...
Vampiric thing.
So you can get his...
Uh...
You can get all his skills back.
And then there's a deflect.
But...
Is it working?
Am I...
Am I doing it?
Wait...
Am I deflecting?
Wait a minute.
Let me double check the deflect.
Where's the right click?
Harry...
To become...
Reducing...
Oh!
It reduces damage.
And decreases the cooldown.
Okay.
It decreases cooldown.
And does like damage reduction.
Okay.
That makes sense.
I was gonna be like...
Where...
Why isn't it going back to him?
Bro is not deflecting.
I was like...
Bro!
Why aren't you deflecting, bro?
What's the point of having a sword if you don't deflect?
But it's just damage reduction.
Okay.
This ult is crazy though.
I don't know how you can...
I'm gonna...
We're gonna be doing like a little...
A show match with like the other content creators.
Um...
But like...
I don't know how you can counter this.
Like...
I don't...
I don't know how you can counter this.
He's trying.
Yeah.
I didn't...
I didn't pay him $0 to block.
Like...
I'm just...
I'm like...
Really curious.
That does not look like it's...
That does not look like you can counter it.
Like...
Oh, I guess Luna ult.
Yeah.
It has to be a support ult.
But it does damage...
Uh...
Heal reduction too.
Did you see that?
There's heal reduction on it.
So I'm like...
Just don't get hit.
Guys.
Just don't stand in a straight line.
We'll be fine.
Yeah.
That does...
That's all I...
Like...
Because there's...
There's healing reduction.
I'll show it again.
Look.
You can see.
The blue is a healing reduction.
So...
Oh, make a...
Build a wall with Groot.
True.
If we build a wall...
Build a house with Groot, it'll be fine.
Right?
It'll be fine.
Just dodge.
Just...
Just walk away.
Forehead.
Um...
But yeah, that's...
Like...
That's basically his ability.
His kit.
Um...
And then...
Slash, slashy, slashy.
Slashy, slashy.
And then there's the whirlwind.
Slashy, slash.
And then...
And then this is the lifesteal.
There's no cooldowns on the lifesteal thing.
So...
You can take that off whenever you want.
Just carry it.
Just block it.
That's all you need.
Yeah.
Wait for Groot to build a house.
And we can all just stay there.
Um...
I think that's really it regarding Blade.
Yeah.
When you're...
You're in the vampire mode.
You can only use your melee.
So that's interesting.
So you can't...
You know...
You can't shoot them when you're like...
I want to suck your blood.
But there's the damage on the gun.
Alright.
Let's do team-ups now.
What are the new...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Did they do it?
Oh no.
They do...
Oh my god.
I want to do this now.
This one.
Pick me up.
Weeeeee.
Okay.
I never got a chance to see that.
That...
Okay.
I'm sorry.
That's like...
That's like hilarious when he gets to fly.
He's like...
Weeeeee.
Alright.
So...
What I want to know...
Is...
How far is the TP?
Alright.
Cause I didn't...
The thing is...
I didn't see a ring...
On it.
Oh.
There's no range.
Wait.
I don't think there is...
What?
Wait.
Guys.
I don't think there is a range.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's try.
And I'm back.
Oh.
Wait.
What?
Oh.
It's there...
Forever.
Oh.
Until someone destroys it.
The cooldown is 20...
Like 30...
I think this was 30...
Oh.
It's actually...
Okay.
You can...
Use that forever.
Yeah.
So there's like...
So if I...
Put that here...
And then I just...
Wee...
This is where the fun begins.
Can you tell I don't play Star-Lord?
Wee...
Am I...
Oh.
It's so...
Yeah.
Cause I was like...
Wait.
When I was watching the trailer...
I was like...
Wait.
There's no range to this.
Oh.
What if you die?
It stays...
I assume when I die...
It's...
Oh yeah.
There you go.
I'm still here.
Okay.
If I die...
It should go away.
Just like Rockets...
Uh...
Rockets thing too.
I assume that...
That's how it goes.
All right.
Let's die first and test it out.
Let's see if it's still here after I die.
That's interesting.
Cause I assume that...
You know...
Yeah.
It's gone when you die.
So...
So at least there's that.
But it does stay there until...
It stays there until you die.
So there's no like...
Cooldown.
The cooldown is only the TP cooldown.
So like...
I guess like...
If you fuck up...
And you know...
You need to like...
An extra escape.
But like...
How fast is it though?
That's the thing.
Oh!
You can move while you're TPing!
Wait!
Oh!
Okay.
That's...
That's scary.
Wait.
You can move while you're...
Can I shoot while TPing?
Oh!
I can!
I can shoot while I'm TPing too!
So I...
I can literally...
If I feel like this fight is gonna...
Go wrong...
I just press like this.
Yeah.
And I can...
That's crazy.
Wait.
That's actually so good for Star-Lord players now.
That's like an extra...
Because like this...
This is like that...
Like...
Um...
It's invincibility frames if I do this correctly.
So...
The fact that I can TP up whenever I want.
Yeah.
And it's like...
There's no range to it too.
Yeah.
They're gonna be so annoyed.
They're gonna...
Oh my god.
That's like a huge...
That's actually such a huge buff to Star-Lord.
I...
That's actually crazy.
Like...
Yeah.
Another escape.
The fact that like...
I can shoot...
While doing the TP.
Like...
Because I could like just be like...
Pew pew pew pew pew.
And like...
See ya.
Mobility having...
You're having mobility.
But it's non-stop.
It's time to break his legs now.
Okay.
Alright.
What is this?
I don't really understand this, Tima.
Uh...
Hawkeye can shoot.
It slows.
When Iron Fist...
He can heal...
Oh!
Wait!
He's an extra healer now.
He can heal nearby allies.
Oh!
So he can...
For all the people who complain about Iron Fist...
At least he can be a healer.
Wait.
Does that mean like...
What's the range though?
How do I activate this?
Oh.
Is it E?
Oh!
When...
Okay.
Oh!
This heals!
That's the healing ability.
I see.
So when I press E.
I heal.
When I press E.
I heal everybody.
Um...
Alright.
What else?
What else is there?
Okay.
So...
I don't...
Okay.
So this one...
I like this...
I like this buff.
So basically if I press E.
And then...
That's looking right.
That's right.
Get out of here!
Eight tempo!
So basically...
Uh...
He...
Oh wait.
So Loki and Mantis...
Has a team up now too.
Uh...
I think this is crazy.
Like...
The fact that...
Look how big this circle is.
I can take up the entire...
If I place my clones correctly...
I could technically take over an entire point.
But I need to match this now.
I can...
Yeah.
I can take up the entire point.
And it is...
Um...
It is...
It increases all stats.
So that includes like damage boost and everything.
Uh...
Do lambs have more HP?
Ooh.
Good question.
We can't test that out.
But everyone has damage boost and speed boost.
I think...
I think speed boost...
I don't know.
It says all stats.
So I assume like it's speed boost as well.
Right?
Yeah.
Oh wait.
No.
It's just damage.
Okay.
It...
It does damage boost too.
So...
So yeah.
Everyone in this circle gets like a damage boost.
Which is actually pretty fucking crazy.
Yeah.
That's a low key Venn diagram.
I can make a...
Guys.
I can make a Venn diagram chat.
Oh my...
That's actually insane.
Oh my god.
I don't really remember exactly what they...
I know like he got...
Okay guys.
What were exactly his buffs?
Because they did so much...
They like changed so many things on Adam that I couldn't even really...
I like lost...
I was like that is the most amount of words I've seen on Adam.
On a patch note.
Yeah.
I was like...
I looked at the patch notes.
And I was like wow.
I've never seen Adam get like more than one sentence before.
That's crazy.
What the heck?
Loki enjoys me.
His charge shots reduces...
Snap cooldowns now.
Oh wait.
Wait.
This reduces cooldowns?
Okay.
Let me...
All right, I'll just waste that real quick.
And then...
Okay.
Oh my god, it does if you hit it.
Yeah, if you hit it, the cooldown reduces.
Yeah.
Revive buff and right... yeah.
It's like... oh wait, it... I get like self heal if I hit it?
All right, let's try.
Oh no, like... oh, cooldown!
Okay, I was gonna say, like, what?
Okay, so if you right click...
Oh my god, I could farm shit with that.
Yeah.
Yeah, finally, it's been... I've never seen Adam with more than one sentence on a patch note.
So I was like, whoa!
You mean he's not gonna be on a wheelchair this season?
Whoa!
So he's playable now.
Oh my god, they finally let him walk this season.
I was so surprised.
I was not expecting that.
Yeah.
You mean they're not gonna take him out back?
What else is there?
Uh...
Guys, what else do you guys wanna see, chat?
Don't say that!
Look, I'm just saying!
He's finally... Oh, he had the Groot wall!
All right.
Don't worry!
I am Groot!
Don't worry, everybody!
I shall build us a wall!
I am Groot!
Oh wait, this is it.
Be healed!
Are you guys being healed?
Oh!
Well, it sucks for that guy.
Oh, there you go!
See?
Be healed!
There you go.
I did my job.
I did my job now.
Okay, so it's only on like...
This ability.
I only have like, one.
It's only one wall that does this.
So it's not as...
It's not as like, good as I thought it was.
But like...
I could...
The thing is...
I'm thinking like...
I could build...
If...
If my team's getting...
Uh...
Getting dove or anything...
I could just like, put a wall.
Yeah, like one special wall.
And...
Okay, I can adjust it.
Okay.
What can I do?
I can do like...
Put a special wall here.
And I was like...
Don't worry little guy.
If the black...
Oh...
If the black panther comes over...
Just stand near my wall.
No, it's only one...
Yeah.
It's only one healing wall.
So...
He still died.
But I didn't expect him to die that fast.
So like...
I could have like a place for him that...
Place for the healers basically.
And there's no like...
Range for that.
Dude.
So it's there until I...
Destroy it.
It's only...
It's there until I destroy it.
Or like if someone else destroy it.
I mean that's cool.
It's like a little extra...
Uh...
Counter to die.
In general.
Yeah, it's like a dab counter.
Which was nice.
Not for heals.
I can place four walls.
But I can only place one heal wall.
See, this is the heal wall.
This is the normal wall.
This is the...
Strong ass wall.
And then...
This is the...
It's like...
It's like I'm actually a...
A...
A builder.
Like I'm building a house.
With different walls.
You know?
Like there's the pillar.
There's the dry wall.
Don't use dry wall by the way.
There's concrete.
So I get three different...
Three different walls to build.
Yeah.
But I can only have one...
I can only have one heal...
Wall that can heal.
Yeah.
I showed blade earlier.
Um...
But he's like a hybrid.
So I can be like...
Pew!
And then like...
And then if I don't feel like shooting.
And I just wanna go ham.
I just do this.
And then...
Pew pew!
Oh, I mean...
Slash slash!
Chop chop!
And then...
Chop chop chop!
I think this one is a cool move.
Cause you can dash if I'm like...
If I'm like...
I don't know...
Being a little rat.
I can do that.
Wait, how...
What's the range for that actually?
What is the range?
How far?
Okay, that far.
It's not that...
Not a very far range.
But it's still like a good...
Flanking thing to do.
Like a gank.
Yeah, it's a slash and dash.
The...
Gun damage is pretty...
I thought it was a shotgun, but...
I'll say the gun does a lot of damage if you hit headshots.
Body shot, not so much.
Which I've noticed.
Oh my god.
The body...
Okay, wait.
The body shot is not...
I mean, it's still pretty...
A lot.
But there is fall off though.
Yeah, it's alright.
There is fall off.
For it.
Which I've noticed.
Yeah, see it's not...
It's not that much.
It's a huge fall off.
Look at the fall off for this.
It's pretty far.
But that's like for body shot.
It does more from range, does it though?
It does not seem like it.
Is it hitscan or projectile?
It feels hitscan.
It feels hitscan but...
Yeah, it does more damage at a...
But...
Really?
Or...
Yeah, I was gonna say...
Does it though?
It does not look like it does more...
Mid-range?
I would say mid-range.
Yeah?
Like, this is mid-range.
And I was like...
I don't think I'm doing more damage.
It's a fire...
It's a projectile?
It feels like a fast projectile.
It feels like...
Fast projectile.
Unbelievable!
Or...
It's either hitscan or fast projectile.
I can't tell if you're sure yet.
That's three of them.
Uh...
It feels very fast for a projectile.
Yeah.
Oh, what else guys?
Is there anything else you guys wanna check out?
Chat?
Next time, put up a fight.
Is there anything else you wanna check out?
Yeah, that's Blade.
I like how I'm...
I like how I'm using...
I'm...
I'm on Blade, but I'm just shooting my gun.
Ha ha ha ha!
Blade with exceptions.
Here they come.
Oh, the Luna...
Okay.
The Luna Summer skin is out now!
So, if you guys wanna see the Luna Summer skin...
Uh, Marvel Rivals is free, by the way.
So, you can download the game right now.
Uh...
With the link on my pin in my chat.
And you can see the Luna skin.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
But I wanna see it...
On stream!
Donkey!
Ha ha ha!
Um...
Let's see.
I mean, there's this team up.
Um...
Which is basically the Moon Knight team up.
Where I'm just invisible.
I can be like...
Peekaboo!
To be fair...
Like...
Yeah, so it's just...
It's just the same as the Moon Knight.
The Moon Knight...
Uh...
Team up.
I'm just gonna make sure I'm not late.
For...
The practice range.
Cause I was last time.
Ha ha ha!
I just...
I wanna be sure I'm not late for that.
You know?
Ha ha ha!
Cause I didn't know.
I...
My Discord had like streamer mode on.
Ha ha ha!
Uh...
Okay.
At 240.
Um...
240.
I have to do the...
The show match.
Alright.
Is there anything else?
I can dash?
Yeah.
Shift is dash.
And then...
The blue is the healing reduction.
Uh...
What?
Another team upside there?
Is that...
Um...
The newest one is...
The Iron Fist one.
Where he could heal players.
This one was crazy.
I think Star Lord has a huge buff for the news...
The half season.
This one's a crazy buff.
Also, by the way.
This is my team.
By the way.
For those who don't know.
It's me.
Fanfan.
Surefour.
Uh...
Moxie.
XQC.
And Boger.
That's my team.
It's pretty stacked.
Not gonna lie.
I was so surprised.
I was like...
What the...
I can't...
I'm on a...
To be fair.
Both teams are also...
Very stacked.
Um...
But like...
I was like surprised.
Cause usually luck is not on my side.
When it comes to randomized teams.
Uh...
Usually...
Usually luck isn't on my side.
I've been very unlucky with randomized teams.
So like...
I'm happy with my team.
Um...
Yeah.
Finally a team that's not six supports.
I was like...
Oh my god.
We each have our roll guys.
We each got our roll.
Alright.
What else can we see?
Check out.
Uh...
Oh yeah.
XQC.
We playing a new Groot.
I think he'll like it.
I mean he is a Groot main.
So I'm pretty sure he'll enjoy it.
Uh...
So good luck sound team.
Good luck sound team.
Balancing all of us.
It's gonna be like...
I feel like it's gonna be very loud.
Yeah.
I mean it's the invisible thing.
So...
I don't think it's like that new.
I think it's just the invisible thing.
Pew.
Pew pew.
I mean slash slash slash.
Sorry.
I don't play melee.
Is it noticeable that I don't play melee?
I don't know.
I'm so bad with melee characters.
Cause it's like...
Why melee when I have a gun?
Like...
Why do I have to be so close to them when I have a gun?
Uh...
Yeah, is this...
Yeah, his dash is invisible?
Yeah.
His dash is invisible.
When you're in this though.
Only when you're in this that it's invisible.
Alright.
What else guys?
Is there anything else you guys wanna see?
I have five minutes left before we have to go into our custom lobby.
Yeah.
Why shank when you can shoot?
I'm not...
I'm...
I cannot play...
I think like I'm...
I'm really bad at any melee character.
Cause it goes against my programming.
Cause I'm like...
Why...
Like I can nearly just shoot you.
Like...
I can be like...
50 miles away and just shoot you.
Like...
And I'll be okay.
We want Luna.
There's nothing!
I don't have skins here!
I don't have skins on this account!
We don't have a Luna summer skin!
I just...
I just have the debuff.
I can't...
What was it?
I don't have the power of anime on my side.
Even though I'm an anime girl.
I don't...
What is this?
I showed the team already, but...
Basically it's like...
Lifesteal.
So I link...
And then...
I get Lifesteal.
Then get it!
Okay.
Fine!
I have free money on this account!
Cause it's not mine anyway.
Uh...
Luna...
Alright...
Cosmetic...
I think it's...
This one?
Yeah.
Alright...
Purchase premium...
And then...
Oh my gosh...
The thong...
Oh my god!
Okay guys, but not gonna lie though...
Like...
Now that I'm here anyway...
Um...
I think...
I think this is not...
Cos...
I...
Legitimately think this is their best low-key skin.
Because like...
When you go...
When you go this way...
Like you can...
Like...
Okay...
Anyway...
Uh...
When you do the side shot...
Like you're...
All right, let's get the... I have enough.
How much is the... Oh, I definitely have enough.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the... Oh, there you go.
So much.
What do you mean?
All right.
I... Do... Okay, I'm gonna say it.
I think...
I think her default skin is her best skin.
Out of all of the skins she has.
Not a fan of the hair color.
I would say... I will say... I will say... Oh my gosh.
The swimsuit design is really pretty.
But... Do I have enough?
Oh, I do.
I just don't like the... The hair color.
But I like this.
I like this swimsuit design.
I like this color.
But...
I don't know.
There's just something about it.
I think her default skin is the prettiest though.
Out of all of the colors.
Of all the skins that she has.
But like...
I want the pink or... I'll do pink and blue.
It's like cotton candy.
I like cotton candy.
All right.
Are you happy now?
Are you happy?
Have you been fed enough?
Have you been fed?
Chat.
Now you won't starve.
Finally some good fucking food.
All right.
Let me make sure that I got everything.
Oh yeah.
By the way.
It is free to play.
For those who have never played Marvel Rivals before.
And all the heroes you can unlock.
You can literally unlock right now.
So it's not like...
It's not gatekept by anything.
So yeah.
You can literally play any of the heroes that I'm checking out right now.
All right.
So...
I just need to make sure...
If I got everything I have to do.
All right.
Technically we have to get ready for the show match now.
We never say no to dessert.
All right.
Let's see.
Custom game.
I think...
Wait.
It's 12 to 12.
How did 12 out of 12 already?
Is this?
Yeah.
There it is.
Wait.
I hope this is not a random room.
Oh.
Player test.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm in.
I was like...
I hope I didn't join a random room.
Okay.
Well, there's only two people there.
So I don't have to be there yet.
Nice.
All right.
You guys want to see...
Okay.
Any new...
This is like the new pass.
The Queen Codex.
Um...
So it's just...
Get ready to...
The...
It's the Widow skin.
And then there's the...
There's the spray here.
And...
Nameplate.
The...
Symbiotic 4.
Gallery card.
Coming soon.
Coming soon means it's coming soon.
Not that you can, like, do anything with it.
There's the...
The emojis.
Gallery card.
The nameplate.
Don King Kong.
Uh...
There's the Venom thing.
The symbiotic thing.
And then I think this one's sick.
I really like this Hella skin.
A lot.
I think the skin is really, really good.
Um...
Out of all the Hella costumes, this one's like the best one.
I feel like.
Oh my god.
It's coming soon, Spray?
Ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
That's something for me.
Okay, we gotta go in the voice chat now.
That's what I'm talking about.
Season 3.5 on August 8th.
That's a week from now.
Wait, am I stupid?
I thought it was August 22nd.
Nope.
It's August 8th.
Whoops, guys.
All right.
Good luck, Sound Team.
Good luck.
I'm meeting myself while I get the foogies up or the Discord stuff.
She just mogged you, buddy.
She just mogged me.
She's ignoring us.
That's crazy.
She don't care, buddy.
All right.
It's okay.
That's life sometimes, isn't it?
Sometimes you'd be like that.
She doesn't know you.
No, bro.
Also, no, bro.
No, bro's important in there as well.
That's okay, guys.
I think I'm going to join the wrong one.
Okay.
I'm here.
Make it for you.
I joined it.
For you.
The voices.
What do they say?
I mean, maybe for me, but...
What do the voices say, guys?
Yeah, maybe I could cook.
Which lobby am I supposed to be in?
I'm trying to figure this out.
It might be a lane type of character.
A me type of character?
Guys, I'm just trying to fix this real quick.
Because tank players don't like anti-heal.
Wait, which one are we supposed to join?
Is it this one?
Guys, it's a lobby.
No, that's the wrong one.
Is it this one?
I'm not joining the slow.
Okay, this is the right one.
The slow isn't that strong, but the...
The reduced healing is going to be really broken.
Okay, I gotta figure out the fookie, guys.
It's been a while.
It seems like it's like...
These days, it'd be the only one to get an actual pick without...
The headshot or something, right?
Like anti-healing.
Oh my god, guys, it's bad.
The fookie's not working.
It's bad.
Okay, wait, I can fix this.
I think you just spam your shotgun, and if any tank gets close, then you start anti-healing them, and then shotgun.
I can't fix this.
Okay, guys, I can fix this.
I think the shotgun's going to be the main damage.
I'm going to be the invite.
The lifesteal isn't as much.
Go to custom game, and then...
Season 3.5 starts on August 8th.
Where is the server?
Okay, global nickname.
Okay, all right, good luck, everybody.
You're going to try and figure out...
Season 3.5 starts, August 8th, free time.
Oh my god, there's so many voices.
My head!
What do the voices say?
Oh man, Negros is here again?
She just tries, man.
Yeah, we gotta win.
Yes!
Damn, you said it, not me.
Yeah, we gotta win.
Wait, wait.
Why is my Fugi not working?
Fugi, please!
There's too many!
Oh, there it is.
Guys, it's working.
Okay, there they are.
They're very tiny, but there they are.
Yes, not me.
There they are.
Wait, does that mean I can do this now?
XCC, you gotta press the button.
No, oh my god, it only has...
You can only press the button.
All right, good luck, everybody.
Good job.
To figure everyone out.
Good luck.
I believe in all of you.
It's okay.
I don't...
I don't scream like you guys.
I don't scream either.
Name it high.
I switched up on my day one, that's what I do, though.
All right.
This is why I switched up on the Loxie.
As soon as I reach you, I have a success, I...
Sorry, guys.
I can't translate for you.
I'm just...
I'm trying to figure this out.
What are you just meaning?
I can't...
Oh!
Why'd he go?
All right, my sound team is figuring out how to sound balance everything.
Rice?
Fried chicken?
Just...
And ketchup?
Yum.
All right.
I love ketchup.
I'm trying to figure it out.
Mustard.
It's goaded.
They're just talking about food!
What is there to translate?
Mustard!
Okay, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Okay, turn.
Sure for it down.
Really set up for that one, huh?
And then... Sound Team's office is on fire right now.
We're trying to figure this out before we do anything.
Why was that so ominous?
I was, uh...
Oh, classic.
Okay.
Sound Team is like, we're trying to figure this out right now.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, I mean, I'm kind of a peasant of humor.
Like, you did it so well.
The delivery, it flew right under my nose.
Okay.
Sure for it's still louder than Moxie.
How is that possible?
Moxie has not upgraded his mic since 2015.
15.
So, I'm waiting on humor.
I, like, have an XQC translator in my chat.
Andrew.
Andrew, the Venom OTP.
Yeah, you guys, like, busted or not?
Not much.
I'm super excited to play Marvel Rivals Season 3.5.
Who are you going to be playing?
Oh, yippee!
I'm going to be playing Cloak and Dagger or Lunas...
Oh, my gosh.
Hey, when is Season 3.5 coming out, guys?
August 8th.
I know this one.
And what is the new character that they're adding for this new season?
Blade.
Oh, my gosh.
Yippee.
Like, from the movie?
Yeah, like, from the movie.
And do I have to pay to play Marvel Rivals?
No, it's for free.
Oh, my gosh.
For free?
For free, guys.
And the character is also free.
You don't have to pay for it.
Wow.
Wow, fascinating.
That is so interesting, guys.
And anyone can download it right now with the links posted in our description.
It's in the pinned message.
Or the pinned message.
All right.
Moxie up a bit.
XTC down.
Fanfan down.
Moxie up.
In the endgame lobbies voice comms because...
...upgraded voice comms system, there's monitoring and moderating in-game.
Yippee!
No more slurs.
No more slurs, guys.
Isn't that great?
I decided to say for chats, so I can filter the words switch and swap when I'm playing Flank Adam.
Ooh, that's really smart.
As long as I can still say Clanker, I'm good.
Whoa, with the hard R?
Yeah, I mean, it's the only way to do it.
You don't want to be a Clanker.
Clanker.
Okay, uh...
I'm fine with Clankers.
You guys are all level 1, dubs.
Booger down.
Fanfan down.
XTC down.
How did you get level 2?
I'm just going to turn Discord down.
Whoa.
You were grinding into Moxie's a good intro.
All right, let me know if it's better, Soundteam.
He's crying so hard.
As a robot, I am deeply offended.
He didn't get the pass, guys.
All right, let me know, Soundgat.
It was better.
Yay.
I can't do my usual, like, Discord overlay.
Usually I do a thing where it just bounces, but for some reason it's not working.
It's, like, so iffy sometimes.
It doesn't show up.
All right.
Moxie, how you got 11 MS?
You want me to low...
Wait, Soundgat, you want me to lower Moxie or up Moxie?
I don't understand.
If he's going to be quiet or too loud.
Wait, why did he ask for ready and then not start, Sus?
Oh, up Moxie.
Okay.
Strange.
Doctor.
Stephen?
Strange.
I'm opening a portal.
All right, I'm up Moxie.
Hmm.
All right.
Anyway.
So, what's up with the...
My XUC translator got everything.
You, um...
You chillin'?
What are you doing these days?
Your hobbies?
My personal life?
Yeah, you got hobbies and shit like that?
And stuff like that?
Not really.
Why not?
Um, I get a little bit lazy.
Why do you do nothing?
Why don't you have a personality outside of streaming?
Yeah, man.
Wait, what are your hobbies?
Oh, wait!
I actually know your hobby.
I've watched...
I really like your music making.
Thank you.
Yeah, I make music.
I drive.
I race.
And stuff like that.
Wait, what's your DJ name?
I love your music stuff.
Yeah.
What's your producer name?
Uh, DTN.
What's the sound?
DJ Toenail.
Yeah.
Do you have a SoundCloud?
Yeah, it's building slowly.
It's building slowly.
Yeah, what's your number one hit?
Number one hit is, um...
All of them.
They're all really good.
You put a producer...
Do you have a Spotify?
No, yeah.
I'm not approved yet.
I'm not approved.
What answer is when producers have a specific sound they play in their songs?
Producer tag.
Oh, yeah.
Do you shout out your name like DJ Khaled?
I thought a producer tag was just their name.
DJ Khaled.
We the best.
Guys, we're starting.
All right.
Thank you.
What team up are we going to do?
We're going to play Blade.
Me.
We can do Cloak and Blade team up first.
That's crazy.
Also, guys, if you have skins, equip the skins.
I can do...
Don't worry.
I got my skin.
I want to get a Cloak and Dagger skin.
Oh, he's talking.
We moxie are in game.
He's only talking game.
He's embarrassing.
Because they buffed it, right?
Yeah, they did.
Overall, healing is better.
Your Ruthman heals more.
It gives more shields too.
That's hot.
Although, it's a group wall.
The healing Groot is pretty good.
Wait.
I'm confused.
C gives me another wall.
Yeah, that's a heal wall.
That wall only heals.
Yeah, you only get one though.
You just hide it.
You just hide it and you heal the entire team and you farm your Ruth.
And it lasts forever.
Yeah.
I think it's pretty OP.
Yeah, you just hide it and it just sits there.
How do you know that?
Because we were in the practice range.
Were you not in the practice range?
What did you do in the first 40 minutes, XTC?
You guys missed when XTC was in the voice chat with me and said, Guys, do I have to watch anything or do anything?
Can I just wait for 40 minutes?
Do the team up.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Now, say it.
This guy put it on European server.
Wait, is he going to live?
Yeah.
I'm betting.
Send me to the death.
Yeah, I was going to say.
Is he going to die?
He's killing me.
I was actually thinking about that RP from the movie.
If you already know.
I might be dying, guys.
Okay?
Oh, my God.
No, we were pretty dead.
So, he's just going to play.
He's just going to play this character.
So, he's just going to do that.
Yeah, can't believe it.
I'm not a team player.
He's going on me.
My controls are wrong.
Wait.
I mean, you didn't set him up, no?
Yeah, I know he didn't.
It's fixed.
Yeah, because when you're on our new accounts, they're all new accounts.
So, we have to reset our settings.
Send me again.
I'm going to fucking die.
Well, we need a team here.
Okay.
My team up is on a 30 second cooldown.
All right.
Oh, my goodness.
All right, buddy.
Okay, guys.
Heal the Venom.
He's stuck in my walls.
He's anti-healed.
Yeah.
Your damage boost, Maxi?
Yeah, I'm watching.
I need a little bit of assistance.
I'm anti-healed.
I'm getting cooked.
Oh, no.
Wait.
You're fine.
You're so healthy.
Nice.
We have to walk through the wall.
I'm anti-healed.
I got my ultimate.
Oh, beautiful.
I'm ulting on to side.
Nice.
I'm going to backline.
Kill the Mantis.
Oh, my God.
We're going to get eaten.
Oh, Venom cut.
Sorry.
Wait.
Who got eaten?
I did it.
I didn't say it.
I'm slicing and dicing right now.
Keep slicing.
We're anti-healed.
We're so much better.
We're so good, guys.
I don't know what happened, but we're so good.
Okay, Maxi, can you send me again?
I'm busy, I'm like a lion.
Yep, I'm ready.
We'll walk in.
Wait, we're going to...
We can burn blade ult.
Nothing can survive.
Wait, that's so true.
Wait, can I damage boost the ult?
Or no?
Oh, this is going to be sick.
Wait, there's a Venom near me.
There's a Venom up here.
I'm with you.
All the Mantis, all the Mantis.
Guys, a little bit of help.
I damage boosted you.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I wasn't ready.
No.
Wait, did you not do it?
I will die.
I did it, but I think I did it too late.
Wait, it's not winnable.
No, we win this.
Honestly, I blame the EU lag.
Wait, mostly popping out.
They're low, they're low.
Pull up, pull up, pull up.
Nice TP.
Go TP.
Thanks, man.
Thanks, thanks, thanks.
Who's Groot?
The hunt is on.
Anti-heal him?
Anti-heal.
Oh, quick.
I'm on Venom.
Venom half.
I'll point, I'll point, I'll point, I'll point.
Kill the Venom, I'll point.
Come on, right?
Sucking him off, sucking him off, sucking him off.
Nice, nice.
I didn't do that.
Do you like that?
Gee, where is that?
Nice.
You guys like that.
Oh, they like capped it a little bit.
Wait, they went triple support.
Oh, they want to win.
I mean, good thing we have a character that reduces healing, you know?
Yeah, true.
It's just true.
We can do cloak ult first, since you...
If you get yours before.
I don't have it yet.
If you get it.
Okay, I will...
I will...
My shotgun's kind of...
Blinded!
Oh, they got a second, they got a second.
Nice.
Nice cut.
I got it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, she has it.
Venom anti-healed, running away.
Weak, coward.
I got you, let's see.
Oh, wait.
I got it.
You have all or no?
Oh, you're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
I'm doing it.
Stabilized.
We are a little bit low.
Oh, they got to be low.
Oh, my God.
I missed everybody.
No, I didn't like this.
Oh, okay.
Get my goob.
Okay, good.
There's a Venom behind us.
He's asleep.
Goop's gone.
That's a big one.
That's a big boy.
Oh, my God.
You're okay.
I can't block the fall.
I can't see you.
It's okay.
It's fine.
We're so low.
I dashed out.
Oh, I'm in it.
No.
It's okay.
We have another portal, right?
No.
We do have a portal.
We need it.
You got to run.
Okay, I'm going.
I can't stall.
Sprinting.
I'm running.
I'm running to you.
Oh, you have to time it.
Oh, my God.
I'm giving you all my seeds.
He's asleep.
I'm touching.
I'm dead.
I'm going point.
Give me a sec.
I'm almost there.
Winnable or lower?
Oh, no.
That shit ain't winnable.
It's just warm up, right?
We're just warming up.
Yeah, we're warming up.
Just like practicing scrims, guys.
Just remember what we talked about.
Yeah, we were all just configuring our settings and senses.
Of course, I forgot to get a skin, so that must be impacting my gameplay.
That is true.
Oh, yeah.
I figured out the buttons.
Moxie, play the Hella with the see-through cape.
Oh, I love that skin.
They're going to make me unleash.
I'm not going to lie.
They're trying too hard to...
You're going to lock in?
Release me, dark magic.
I'm locking him in now.
Dark magic.
Oh, my God.
I'll play it.
These inhibitors are off, guys.
You should be telling one trick.
Yeah, no.
I'm lost.
What are you saying, man?
Yeah, I didn't have roll input on.
That's why.
Hold on.
I just got enabled by the team up.
XTC is ascending.
Four.
Is it?
Two.
One.
All you need to do is capture the mission.
I believe you.
Tips for Thor, by the way, sure.
Four.
Yeah, you awakening and then you spam at them and then you get builded again and spam at them and you go on to their backline and you E and then you all.
Okay, I'll try.
Mid fight.
Just go on their backline.
Okay, I'm going into the backline.
Oh, there's Groot Wasp.
We can't get to you.
I'm watching Shirt 4.
I got one.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm swapping.
I'm backing out now.
I'm winnable.
Oh, we're engaging.
Winnable.
Should I be the guy that pulls out Wolverine?
Yeah.
Do it, do it.
Yeah, yeah.
Be that guy.
Be that guy, be him, be him.
We ain't losing, bro.
We ain't losing.
We got walled.
I'm going to get staggered.
Wait, unless...
No, I'm dead.
Wait, you guys are alone.
Nah, you're kind of cooked.
Yeah, you don't have supports with you.
No, it's fine.
They didn't...
Healing bubble.
We're coming over.
Get him, get him, get him.
If I can use ult first.
I'm lost.
Yeah.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
Oh, there's going to be...
Nice, nice ult.
Woo, get in my ult.
Oh, my God.
There is a group right behind us, by the way.
Beautiful, beautiful.
There's a group behind.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I gumbode with you.
That's cool.
I need going up.
There is a venom on point.
Beat him.
Nice.
Guys, please shoot him, shoot him, shoot him, please.
I beg, I beg, I beg.
I got denim, he's so far.
You didn't save my bait.
Where is he going?
Where am I going?
Oh, I quit all the time.
We got venom.
Yeah?
We'll die!
I quit all the time.
Okay, we're coming back.
Healers are coming back.
I believe.
Alright, I'm waiting, I'm waiting.
Oh, I got this.
I ain't using this.
I would say, even though they buff Mantis, I don't know.
I don't know, but it has a duo of support.
It's fine.
We win this.
They're triple healing right now.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But we have a character that reduces healing, so, you know?
Easy counter.
Yeah.
That's true, that's true.
Right, right, right.
Be on.
I got...
Oh my god!
Oh my god, they just doubled.
Kill this guy.
He's one, he's one.
Beautiful.
Nice.
This is our last fight pretty much, so...
Yeah, this is last fight.
We're not more walking out.
I don't have enough heals right now.
So it's up to...
It's up to back.
I'm healing my...
I'm spamming.
We have a winner.
You just me up.
I'm trying to keep...
Oh my god.
Guys, get ready.
Nice.
I'm ready.
I'm ready as well.
I'm pushing up.
I'm killing you Loki.
I got grabbed, guys.
I missed.
Loki TP.
I slept.
I slept Wolf.
Mantis dead.
Beautiful.
Kill this Wolverine.
I'm slicing and dicing.
Yeah, slice and dice.
Oh my...
Through one.
That's fine.
Come back there, Jeff.
They're on Wolverine.
They're on Wolverine as well.
They've been on Wolverine for a bit.
You caught this.
There is a Venom on...
We can win this.
Nice.
I don't have kidnap for three.
Venom half?
He's just...
I got soldered.
I keep whooping him.
He's just running.
Wait, he left.
We win this.
Well, the born skilleting dad is tracking your numbers.
Don't worry about this.
The Gombo.
The Gombo?
Yeah.
We gotta make sure you live.
I'll live.
Just press the E button.
I think you survived.
They're Groot's on top right.
All right.
He's gonna try to lob him.
He's grabbed.
How about the Groot?
Oh, he's blind.
He slept.
Venom blind.
I'm ready for the ult.
You only got one.
It's not great.
But it's fine.
No, it's good.
It's good.
We win this.
Let's kill the Mantis.
There's as much as we need.
Mantis, Mantis, Mantis.
I need heals, I need heals.
Bubble, bubble, bubble, bubble.
Thank you.
Venom.
No passive?
Oh, I'm shotgunning him.
Oh, beautiful.
Nice.
Nice, we win.
Short, smaller numbers than big numbers.
Yeah, it's better to ult than not ult at all.
Segmentation is way, way better.
More efficient.
We'll run into the ult.
You're damage boosted in here.
Very nice.
Wait, one of them is supposed to play in.
Oh, there's a...
They're trying to win.
They're really one ult.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
I'm slicing and dicing.
Wait, group one, group one.
Nice.
I got you.
I got him up.
Dead.
Nice.
Good fade.
Guys, have another one on the suit.
Don't worry, we only have Venom over here.
We still have Venom over here.
Guys, let's go cook the mantis.
They realize one of them needs to play Blade.
Just like staff DMs.
Um, where's Blade?
Feel better.
Fight better.
You're ult to the top for heart.
Alright.
Anti-healed.
Venom behind me.
I have Gombo.
Uh, yeah.
No, forget it.
No, no.
Gombo, no Gombo.
We comboed.
Nice.
You saw our ult.
I already used it.
Venom, Venom, Venom.
Venom's doing that thing again.
Damage boosted.
Where is he?
He got him, guys.
He was running around.
Rat!
Nice.
Did you say rat?
Wait!
Strange on the suit on me!
I'm gonna be dead.
He's a rat.
He's a land shark.
Land shark.
Guys, there's a...
There's a...
Can we kill the...
Oh my god.
He came back so fast.
Guys, kill the...
He's coming back.
I'm grabbing him.
I anti-healed him.
Moxie is fighting their spawn?
Come on.
You got to see.
I'm trying to play out!
I'm shooting the shot, bro.
Guys, please shoot the shot!
No way.
No way!
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh.
I'm killing, I'm killing, I'm killing.
Oh, wait.
This is bad.
I did not have my ult.
Uh-oh.
Oh no.
I can't get to you.
Do we have portal?
I can!
Do I have TP?
I'm trying so hard to move.
Okay.
I don't think we have time, guys.
I think we're good.
No, I didn't think so.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I can dash through.
I dash through.
Go through the back, go through the back.
No!
C-die!
How do we lost the fight, because I kept shooting the venom, but I was the only one shooting the venom.
But, I think we need to kill Jeff there though.
Okay.
There was a stranger behind us.
I think we shot him in the back.
Spawn is good, no?
What was the plan behind the spawn camping there?
You know, it was a group effort that we did.
Wait, our Wolverine was in spawn?
Yeah, he was spawn camping.
We have Garmin agents in our game.
Yeah, but holding what though?
The TP.
What are you holding there with TP, bro?
When the TP went away and I got stuck there.
Who exactly were you holding in your spawn?
Holding the yellow.
The voices, bro, the voices.
The voices, what do they say, Moxie?
Yeah, what do they say?
I was holding an L, yeah.
Yeah, you were holding an L.
Yeah, that's life.
That's life, damn right.
So wise.
Thank you.
Honestly, for my first game back, I feel like I'm pretty confident.
You did great.
Yeah.
I'm gonna try out the new Atom changes.
I wanna play Luna.
Don't worry.
I got the best skin for Luna to motivate us.
Oh, fine, fine.
Pull out the Loki.
Or the Mantis, actually.
You can go Mantis.
For the team up.
The Groot team up.
Which one do you guys want?
Do you guys want the Loki team up?
For the...
Oh, guys.
Look at this.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Loki team has damage boost, too.
Yeah.
This is terrorism right here.
Big lamps.
Yeah, and the big ass lamps, too.
Yeah.
We got a lot of damage.
I think it's pretty stable.
Wait.
XTC can just plant the wall and you can just farm his ult.
Oh, my God.
What's that?
Wait, hold on.
Don't worry.
I'm playing DPS.
Okay.
Go Mantis, go Mantis.
Me?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're just gonna farm.
XTC, so...
Okay, okay.
I think it should be pretty fast.
Just double my FPS.
All right.
Oh, beautiful.
Very good.
Beautiful.
I'm ready.
I think I was playing on 60 frames, guys.
But it's okay now.
I'm playing on 500 frames.
Full potential unlocked.
Three, two, one.
All right.
I'll give Moxie the...
Oh.
Really?
What year is this?
The mic even shut out.
It had to happen to one person.
No, I expected more from you, FanFans.
Yeah.
There's someone up here.
I'm disappointed there, I'll be honest.
Does it say...
Only play Venom?
Someone in the back, someone in the back!
Yeah, it's Andrew.
Guys.
It's number one EU Venom.
Andrew's playing Strange right now.
Guys, I need a little bit of assistance.
I'm reduced healing.
They're cooking me.
Guys, they're gonna cut off here.
We can kill them right here.
There is a blade.
I'm shooting the Strange.
Strange sandwich, you guys.
I'm putting the wrong buttons completely.
Oh, I have a healing wall kinda cool.
There's a Strange right behind us.
There is a blade up.
Oh, there is a.
Not a blade.
Kill one of his blind.
You got him, bro.
You got this.
I really don't got him.
Guys, you can kill the VP.
Come on.
I got him.
Nice.
Let's get him, guys.
Let's go.
Unit.
I'm going into Luna.
I'm here.
I'm so scared.
Don't be scared.
Okay.
Just believe.
I'm getting quick, guys.
I'm getting quick.
I'm more close.
You are so far up.
How is she not the grenade agent?
Oh, I'm trying.
Dang.
I did the link and everything, too.
What?
Guys, this is a quick play game.
I want to point out this is a quick play.
Explain!
We're doing great, guys.
I believe in us.
Guys, we got this.
We got this.
Okay, watch this.
We're here.
We're all together now.
I have no idea what the hell I'm doing right now.
Okay, I got you.
I got Snowflake on you.
Wait, Booger's twirling.
Where is there Luna?
Everything's fine.
Okay, guys.
I'm ready.
I'm gonna TP high ground.
I know where the Luna is.
So, um...
Worse bit.
You wanna clear above?
Where?
Boom.
Oh, my God.
Would you be okay?
We got him.
Please.
Where's my team?
Me!
I got you, Tin.
I mean, we TPed.
Guys, I'm teleporting around the map.
Oh, my God.
Are you guys so nice?
What is the guy doing?
Wax, I'm ready for the combo.
I'm ready for the combo.
I don't know what's going on.
Oh, you already did it.
Oh, I ulted, but like...
I have a black panther on me.
It's okay, we have res.
Oh, huge res.
Huge res.
Huge res, huge res.
You guys, excuse me.
Oh, wait, me and me.
That is you, that is you.
Guys, I am getting res, it's fine.
I...
Oh.
There's thunder.
I got it.
I'm so dead, though.
Do you want blade?
I'm just like Adam right now.
We're still alive, it's okay.
I don't know what I'm...
No, you believe in yourself, Moxie.
I got more.
Moxie, just slash.
Slash the dash.
Oh my...
I got one!
Beautiful, beautiful, beautiful, beautiful.
anko pool.
Maybe I'll just give the- There's a BP up top.
He's going in.
Yeah, he's going up.
I froze him.
Nice grab.
We got this.
I hit that big one, big one.
I believe.
Wow, we have a huge...
Was it big?
Oh, caught him, caught him.
He's one!
I got him, I got him!
Get a Groot, get a Groot.
Groot cut!
They're going to tep!
Get the Black Panther!
Who's going to cancel the tep?
Who's going to cancel it?
Nobody!
There's a blade behind us!
Barger.
I believe in that 1v1.
I can just spawn myself in front of them!
You got to get your eyes off!
Okay, that's true!
Wait, there is TP!
I'm with you, booger.
Can you heal me up?
Yeah, of course.
Thank you.
Absolutely.
I got a group.
Nice.
You're so linked.
Never die.
Beautiful.
I'm cutting him out.
You said that when you weren't even here.
Ohhhh.
Don't worry.
I got this.
Do you have rest?
Oh, he does.
He does.
I have ult too, right after.
Oh, they used everything.
Fort again!
Oh man.
We all live.
Okay.
You're all out.
Hell they got.
Oh.
I'm ready.
That's you.
I got you booger.
Get this guy.
This guy.
A point, a point.
Train to the back.
This guy is the stall master.
Nice.
You guys go back a little bit.
I go up.
I'm gonna walk them out.
I got combo with you too.
Yes, no flake.
X, I got combo.
Let me know when you're looking.
And in mind, they can wall me off if you do it.
But I'm like, I'll be ready.
Groot's on the right.
Don't worry, I'm mind controlling him right now.
He's won, he's won.
Was he just focused on you?
Yeah.
Nice mind control.
I think he's over here somewhere.
I could've healed you there.
That's not me.
Oh my god.
That's unfortunate.
But he is one.
Oh, he's getting healed.
I'm dead.
There's a passenger behind.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, are we still playing?
Wait, I died.
I got this.
I got my one.
Oh, we actually are on quick play?
Yeah.
I thought you were unironically.
This feels like a quick play team.
What is happening back there?
Let me fix my key binds, guys.
I got this.
I got you, Maxi.
Yes, nothing.
No, my heal didn't go up.
You're so healthy.
Oh, okay.
We win this.
I full bugged myself.
That was crazy.
I don't see you.
No, there was a...
I'm sorry.
There was nothing I could do.
I can't do it.
Is this Kenny person like a fucking one-trick guy on the ground of Jeff?
I'm kidding.
I'm just crazy.
Jeff down.
Jeff's a problem.
Yeah.
Well, they're dead right now.
I'm dead.
You're okay.
They're ATP 'ing, guys.
They're ATP'ing.
I need HP.
It's fine.
We're so healthy.
I have love.
Oh, no, no.
I'm running.
They're TP'd, but I don't know why.
They got it.
They're gonna get out of me.
You're fine.
Beautiful.
X, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Alright.
We do this.
X, I'm ready.
Vinny, Vinny.
Yup.
You got one.
There's two.
There's two in there and these.
It's all of them.
Yeah, yeah, there's all of them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw like seven people in there.
Ooh, first kill, boys.
All my friends, guys.
Supports are on cart.
So if you guys need keys...
Oh, I'm just going to get a big one, guys.
Get ready for this one.
Oh, God, I can't reach you.
No, my heals was going to the...
Don't worry, I'm just passing.
Yeah, come back, come back, come back, come back.
Okay, we are so...
Oh, I just accidentally dashed.
Uh-oh.
That's it, that's it, back up, back up, back up.
Oh, Baki.
I think he is.
Got you, got you.
He's alone in every way.
He's going to stuck out.
He dashed up before I could dink.
There's a BP up top.
Oh, wait, wait, he fucked up.
Let's go, let's go.
He tripped.
We got him, we're done.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He tripped and fell.
BP to the back.
Yeah, I'm dead here.
We got to triple.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I have a BP up.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
Trip on.
Born again.
Oh!
Oh, we have a man as well.
He's ready.
Where am I?
He's won, he's won.
Oh, Black Panther's one.
Got him, got him.
Oh, my God, he got him.
Help!
We're fine, we're fine, we're so fine, we're so fine.
I'm here, right here.
Get the rat!
The rat is just swimming away!
He's won, he's won!
Get him, get him, Max, get him!
I'm out, I can't do it!
No, I'm not chasing him, bro.
I'm pushing in.
Jeff just behind.
That's fine.
Guys, there's a BP here.
It's so fine.
Winnable.
I believe...
Oh, never mind.
Oh, I don't know if you lived that.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Careful, careful for the healing!
Oh no, he's last fight!
Oh!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
FTP, FTP, FTP, wait, wait, wait.
Listen, listen, listen.
I have to be, I'm swapping.
Okay, Sure4 is like on a mission right now.
We got this, we got this.
I'm opening a portal.
Okay.
I got both DPS.
I can board again though.
Behind you, there's a brain!
I don't know what's up here.
Oh my god.
Oh, there's...
Oh, there was a platform!
I died.
Oh, oh.
I'm getting even.
Again, man.
Oh my god, bruh.
It's okay, you got board again again, right?
That was so close.
I got another portal.
Yeah, yeah, portal again.
Oh my god, the shark.
That's pretty close.
Stupid rat shark.
I think if we have the defense there, we win.
First point hold.
I think we had a...
They're...
...bladed in SVP.
One of them left.
They left?
Oh.
Yeah.
Probably scared.
They just GG says.
They're scared of getting mugged.
They're like, that's enough practice.
It's so chaotic.
Wait, two of them left.
Anyway, fan fan, do you play RP?
Nope, I haven't in like two...
A year and a half, maybe.
Oh yeah, same.
What does an XTC ask me questions?
Yeah.
Because I know you more than I know her.
Okay.
Yeah.
We did play together a lot.
Yeah, unfortunately.
What do you mean by that?
You got beef with the XTC?
I've been saying in a long time, to be fair.
No, I'm just saying, I'm just saying, as a player, you're a load, you know?
I'm just like, everything seems so fast.
I'm playing like very slow games.
Can you define what a load means?
Everything was like, I'm like, oh my gosh.
Can you readjust how fast everything is?
Listen, what do you mean by these are loads?
I'm saying, if your team has six surfboards, you're going nowhere.
No, they're winning grand finals, a hundred percent.
If your team has six XQCs, they wouldn't be playing the game.
Yeah, yeah, we wouldn't even get through the lobby.
And I know that for a fact, though.
It's not a bad thing, but a little bit of surfboard I can handle.
It's just a little bit.
But too many in this, a little bit too big a load.
Dude, too much, I can't.
What's the maximum amount of surfboards you can handle?
God, listen, one lobby of surfboards I can do a day.
Two hours of scrims.
Lag.
Sorry.
30 seconds before you attack, get ready.
Boger on Hella?
I'm just showcasing the new skin that's coming out with season 3.5.
Wow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look at this.
Look at this, guys.
Look at this skin.
Isn't it beautiful?
Yeah, and you can buy it on August 8th.
August 8th, I'm right.
Yeah, with the premium pass, guys.
There will be 990 coins.
It's looking cool.
That is neat.
Wait,
guys, can you come to spawn real quick?
Oh, yeah, I got you.
Most of them are bad.
Yeah?
Oh.
Wait, that's an actual e-vote?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, they did.
Oh, I don't want to see anyone.
I didn't realize that was...
I thought it was just fan art.
I'm everywhere.
Okay.
Above us, there's a guy.
Wait, they have born again now.
Is there a turn?
Born again?
Yo, I'm main.
We can kill the old man right here.
I'm shooting out.
Clapping, clapping.
We got a beautiful.
Can we get the blade here?
I used two laps accidentally.
That's okay.
I'm on the blade.
He's one.
Beautiful.
The rat, the rat.
Can we get the rat?
There's a torch that's just dying, by the way.
He's like one.
He's the back guy like, oh my god.
Hey, there's a born again right in front of us.
And I think he's gonna born again here.
He said, oh no.
No, no.
Nazi Nazi.
No, no, no.
Oh, yep, yep, yep, yep.
Come back.
He's anti-healed.
Um, what are you doing here?
Wait, what are you doing here?
What are you doing?
I'm like stealing.
Aha, beautiful.
I'm dead.
I have to reload.
I'm sorry.
BLEH!
Wait, Jeff is one.
Fucking rat on point.
I got him.
I had to reload though.
Yo, these are totals.
They're like optimized like new age tiktok potals or something like what?
Like, what is that?
It's assault heart without going through the portal.
I mean, that's crazy.
He went on the other side.
The other side.
Tiktok potals in a custom lobby.
It's crazy.
Listen, I lagged out.
No healing.
No space.
No DPS.
Dive shit.
But you're the Hulk.
You're the one making...
Yeah, you're the one making...
Dive shit.
I grade space and what he like...
Oh, if I'm...
You get an old space.
I was running from spawn after I died.
A classic...
I'm bad, I'm bad, I'm bad, I'm bad, I'm bad.
I was about to be able to do that with you, but then I died.
I got him.
Cook him.
Is that the whole reason you went Hulk?
I'm not moving.
I forgot to do the confirmed thing.
This guy went Hulk using solo ult Necros.
I rolled him.
Rolled him.
Oh, don't worry.
I'm dancing.
Got his ass.
We're five.
Don't worry.
Where's your rat now?
Oh wait, he has board again.
Oh, in, in, in, in.
Oh, shit.
Oh, we're not in there.
Oh, I am.
What the hell?
I am strange.
Are you okay?
You are strange?
Are you having good times?
Wait, we're kissing.
We're in a very beautiful embrace.
Nice.
Did he only rest one person?
I think so.
He was.
Yeah.
Oh my god, this chain is forever.
There's no way this guy went Wolverine because I bullied him.
He's had enough.
He's had enough with what your shit.
Don't worry, I'm making Venn diagram.
Thank you.
Well, that was very well done.
I didn't have a good day.
Bag lamp.
Okay, I can't do anything about that though.
I might be cooked.
I can't do it.
I got a thousand gaunted.
I feel like I was blocking.
Yeah.
Where's the short four?
I think it's on me at the start.
You're all alive thingy.
Where's our combo?
He's chasing me.
Different hero.
Why didn't the short four do that?
What that guy just did.
Yeah.
Why didn't we have...
Why does the Loki have MVP?
There's a terrorist on me.
He's chasing me.
Please.
Their blade has MVP.
Wolverine.
Wolverine on me, guys.
He's chasing me.
Guys, I'm creating space.
I'm creating space.
Please push up.
One for one.
So Wolverine's on him.
Who's on him again?
I think the Wolverine.
Flats!
No, not Flats, Wolverine.
No, not Flats.
Fuck it.
Guys, help me.
Is it big?
What are you...
It's not long, guys.
No, we need it.
We need it.
Get in the...
I'm trying to...
Get in the lab!
He's a wolf over there.
I need helping.
Inside of us.
Okay.
Are you...
Are you guys...
Do you guys still need help?
Do you guys...
Wait, I have my ult.
I have my ult.
Nice.
Four.
Three!
Yeah, yeah.
We're in.
Hoping's level.
Oh, I know.
Squirrel, go.
Squirrel stampede.
Why is no one shooting the squirrels?
I don't know.
I have ult, I have ult, I have ult.
I'm holding it a little feeling.
I'm healing, I'm healing.
I'm healing you.
I don't have to heal anymore.
I have ult on points.
Oh, they're getting cutted.
Is everybody okay?
I can't tell.
I'm chilling.
How are you?
Everything's going great.
I am not okay.
This fight has been forever.
That looks great.
Oh my god, we made it.
Just like Scrooge.
Hey, that took all my juice, by the way.
That was a long fight.
You're juiceless for the rest of the game.
We gotta carry.
Yeah, I mean, that was crazy.
I'm not washed.
I locked in.
Hey, let's go.
That's the rank one Groot.
Look at that.
We have five minutes to push it.
We can't fuck up.
The Groot.
You forgot.
It's fine.
Oh, we have to win.
And then they can't even fight back.
Because it's quick play.
Exactly.
That's so true.
We're demoralizing them.
Guys, they have a cap.
And an Ultron.
I have one.
No, we don't have it.
These guys are like comboing like it's a rank game.
Tap on point.
There's like no changes on them.
We're not gonna have them.
On the point, on the point.
Captain America, on the point.
Oh, I can't.
This guy really wants us.
I beat X.
I'm building it.
How long?
Guys, I need a little bit of healing.
Here you go.
It's all right.
I'm eating the Strange.
This is your healing.
I got it soon.
Eat him.
Oh.
I have it.
I'm dancing.
Three, two, one.
It's over.
I can't do it.
I'm ready whenever.
A thousand cuts.
There's a Captain America on me.
He has no heals.
He's won.
I'm in the spawn.
The voice line too.
Dude.
You did it.
You did the combo.
I buried the light.
Watch out.
He's dancing.
Bursing on me.
On me.
Okay, but they're all like respawned already.
So.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
He's doing it bad.
I have to reload.
Ben, don't go.
I had to reload.
I got him.
Oh, wow.
Eyes around the wall.
Oh, my god.
Please.
I can't heal forever.
I'm returning slowly.
No, guys.
We lost his fight.
Why did we go mad?
It's okay.
We have another combo.
Oh, no.
Oh, my god.
I'm trying my heart.
No, big.
This is big.
I'm healing too.
I'm also healing.
Oh, this is big.
You're healing.
I killed him.
Please did.
I got that ultron.
Get him.
Quick his ass.
Oh, my god.
Got him.
Nice, nice.
Game-winning heals right there.
I will ult in a second.
I'm holding it.
Yep.
Using it.
Ours is much better than theirs.
Yeah, I believe.
All right.
You got a mecha blow?
Three, two, one.
It's gone.
It's fine.
I have ult.
I may have points in my ult.
Hell, yeah.
No, we need that for the group.
I'm ahead.
All right, here we go.
I'm sorry, Surefour.
If you did, one more second.
It's okay, it's okay.
I don't have combo.
I may have wasted it.
That's why I'm getting strange with hair.
Oh, huge.
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
That's the scene.
Cook him.
Beautiful.
He's one.
Ultron.
One.
I'll run that.
Lunapoi!
No, no, no, no.
Blade, Blade!
Frozen, nice.
Yippee!
Dude, I still got it.
Oh, these guys got the roads.
That was just a sword fest between me and the Captain America.
What?
See, we were fucking around in the last match and it was still close.
Yeah, we turned on.
I was boiling.
You were boiling?
You're boning.
Dude, no, shut up.
I was getting into business.
Holy.
Remember that?
Yippee, dude.
Wait, did they swap sites because they want to beat us?
No?
Yeah.
Was that why they swapped sites?
Oh, he said oops started same map.
Yeah.
Oh, sure.
Sure.
It's a little oopsie.
Are you stupid?
That's why you got to ask him then.
Yeah, you can put versions in check.
Let's see.
I am Loki.
I mean, Loki's really good on this one.
I know Bruce can't change it.
Well, I think I can mute on Discord whenever.
You have to do admin mode.
You have to launch.
Do you need to launch in admin?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
And then you can play this on August 8th, free to play with Blade.
Oh.
True, true.
What date?
August 8th.
That's a week.
Yeah.
In a week, guys.
And every hero is free to play.
Just a week away.
Blade is just a week away, guys.
Even Fanfan's dog is excited.
That's crazy.
He's like, August what?
August what?
The battle starts in 5th.
How come seeing guy hogs is because Moxie doesn't like to play Blade?
I think I need to keep the map.
Why are we like...
Why aren't we defending?
I mean, I mean...
Why did they play...
Why are we on offense again?
That's a damn.
Why are we doing this all over again?
Why are you in main, in main, in main.
He won.
Get out of here.
We can do this again.
Did this guy literally restart to try and win again so they can make a YouTube video about beating XTC three times in a row?
There's a guy I got.
Here you go.
I'm with you, bro.
I used lap though for it.
No laps, no laps.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
No worries.
Wait, Andrew's on Squirrel Girl.
Yeah, he's been playing Squirrel Girl.
I'll stop behind you guys.
He's low lap.
I died.
Oh, no.
You got a murder right there.
Guys, I didn't know that.
Oh, no.
Nice.
Wait, they're putting everyone on their mains.
Except for Andrew on Squirrel Girl.
No, that's actually a character he plays in my run games.
But like, because he hates you?
He's a Squirrel Girl Venom player.
No, no, no.
He thinks it's actually good.
Isn't there like a really actual, really good Squirrel Girl player in the EU?
I couldn't hear you.
I'll be honest with you.
Clear, clear upstairs.
Go do up.
Clear comms, guys.
Clear comms.
Oh, jeez.
I'm cold.
I used lamps because of this.
Vendor, Vendor, Vendor.
I have my ult.
I'm trying to help you guys.
Oh, my God.
You guys, come here, come here, come here.
I'm stuck.
Goodbye.
It's okay.
You got health kills.
Thank you.
Goop.
I got the group kills.
What?
Oh, my God.
What happened?
That can't be good.
I don't even know.
I think shotgun and nut.
Oh, my God.
I can die through my ult like that?
I don't need to do the confirmed thing.
Bleh.
There's a confirmed thing for Loki's.
Don't worry.
We almost have combo.
We're almost there.
Wait.
He's actually still got it.
He's still got it.
I'm going to bubble you.
Oh, you're good.
Oh, my God.
A healing bubble.
Okay.
That's the Groot right there.
That's the Groot.
Can you kill the blade?
And he's got another one.
All right, guys.
Oh, he's so talented.
Blade 1.
We're heading over to you guys.
I'm here.
Oh, my God.
I have many faces.
Don't worry.
There's a Groot on the cart.
There's a fake Groot on the cart, guys.
Coming.
He is still alive.
We don't have combo anymore.
We don't need combo.
I saw the lag.
No more combo.
Put a healing bubble.
Oh.
Almost there.
I'm in though.
I'm in.
He's always up.
Oh, my God.
Nice lamps.
Why can't I?
Oh, my God.
I couldn't fucking get to you.
It's fine.
Oh, you see me.
Nah, I hooked them.
Nice.
See, they didn't want to go.
They were so scared of my Groot.
Guys, can you push up?
Can you push up?
Clear crumbs.
Push up.
I got this.
I got to win this.
All right.
I'm pushed up.
I'm pushed up with you.
I'm out.
Beautiful.
Behind you.
You're getting three Loki clones healing you.
I'm just going to get in the cockpit a little bit.
Okay, he's on his main.
They're actually all just on their mains.
They actually restarted just to try and get another win.
Okay, that'll be so embarrassing for them if they lose again, right?
I canceled his tether.
I canceled his thing.
Nice, nice, nice.
No passive.
Why is no one helping me?
I can't get him.
He's low.
He's so low.
Oh, I didn't have him.
And then I die.
And then...
Why did you just get all my kids on the ground?
I'm going to die.
With the gunman.
Hello?
He was running away.
He ran into his team.
I think he's as bad as this.
I'm coming back.
I have my ultimate.
You don't understand.
They need that ad revenue.
Ultimate.
Guys, there's a BP right side.
Diff him, Oxi.
Diff him.
Wait, I don't...
Oh.
You're looking at the enemy not the friendly.
No, I'm looking at my healer.
Ben-Fan, we need heals.
We need heal.
We need a little bit of healing.
I see you.
We have Doki Bird alive.
I was behind you.
Okay, well, I can't.
That is...
No, you can't pay it away.
I don't see you.
You can't pay it away.
Just cut, just cut.
You know what?
I'm not looking at Doki Bird anymore.
That's it.
I'm not laughing her either.
Oh, that's a big one.
That's a big one.
Oh, no, there's an in war.
It's me!
That's huge.
It's massive.
There's massive.
No follow-up.
I need one damage there.
One damage.
Why can't we get one damage there?
There's so many people.
Because I was peeling my back line.
No lab, no lab.
He has all the...
They both started saying they're not going to peel each other.
So I had to be the one to peel.
No, I'm peeling her.
Of course.
What the hell?
She's my priority.
What?
I'm just playing horse-eye.
What do you mean I was texting bro?
I was texting everyone.
I made a Venn diagram and everything.
The wolf's coming out.
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
Do I just ignore the Venom?
I think I'm the only one shooting it.
I got him.
I might just...
I have to dive them, I think.
Oh my, I'm just...
Bubble for you.
You are so...
Tried to solo off the Venom.
Damn right.
He's one, he's one.
He's actually one.
Guys, can you heal me up?
Can I get a lamb?
No.
We have to use him.
We're getting terrorized back here.
Buy what?
Why is this guy?
I don't have...
Oh my, goodbye.
Your supports are at you too.
Why is X to see on fucking BP?
Bro, I just...
I said I have to dive them.
You have to dive this, bro?
Let him cook.
Oh, we're so frightened.
Oh, he sees my link.
He's slept, bro.
Guys, we're gonna be a YouTube video, guys.
Bro, bro, bro, bro, bro, bro.
This candy player has like a fascination to annoying me.
Like, it's...
She's rage baiting, rage baiting.
She's rage baiting.
I'm getting TikTok farmed again.
Uh...
So you can...
Oh, no, he's here.
He's one, he's...
Oh, he's so low.
Holy shit.
I need a little bit.
Here, here, here, here's the lab.
Look at you, look at you.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
Oh, I can't...
Oh, my use...
There is a Panther behind us.
There's a Venom behind us, too.
In here, in here, in here.
In the tunnel.
Guys, Venom's on point, Venom's on point.
Venom won.
He's one HP.
Oh, beautiful.
Okay, I believe in you, XQC.
You got this.
You're faster than him.
Wait, it's a 1v1.
It's a 1v1.
Yeah, 1v1.
1v1.
Guys, there's...
Wait, watch the 1v1.
Guys, it's a 1v1, not a 5.
Guys, guys, they're on cart.
They're on...
Guys.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
We're watching.
Is Shrefour winning?
Oh my god, I'm nearly on.
My ship got cancelled.
I'm healing, I'm healing.
Oh, kill this guy, kill this guy.
Oh, beautiful.
Nice.
I tried to block the damage, but I took the damage.
Oh, that's a huge one.
Nice, nice.
Venom on point.
Yeah.
Venom, I landed, but he's just on cart.
Black Panther on point.
Oh, it's okay.
I'm slowly heading over.
Maybe I'll get him.
Venom.
What's that ult?
What are we doing with this?
That is so unlucky.
Damn.
Guys, I believe you.
Venom.
Guys, ult, ult, ult.
Okay, Moxie hits a big ult, we win.
Yeah, I'm reloaded.
Yeah, this is on me.
Oh, you.
If we don't win this, it's because of you.
I can combo your ult soon.
Okay, okay.
I'm doing a reload.
I have it.
All right.
I had to ult, lamb.
Okay, I'm, I'm in the...
Oh, no.
Uh-oh.
Intect the Venom ult.
All right, you need a big one here, Moxie.
Yeah, you need to do it now.
I got two.
You gotta do it now.
I ulted it.
Nice, nice.
Do the Jeff.
Yeah, no supports.
There's no Venom.
Venom.
I can't.
No supports.
I'm fleeing back.
Don't see none.
I'm with the Venom.
Venom cut.
Nice.
We got that guy, right?
It's the Jeff.
No, we got this.
We got this.
You got this, right?
I'm gonna wait and spawn then.
Is he fighting the Jeff?
Yeah.
Yes!
Excuse me.
Dude, you sound like you're being assaulted.
Jeff is with you.
He is being assaulted, bro.
You guys are killing me?
Guys, there's a Jeff behind us.
Oh my god.
I got the Jeff, I got the Jeff.
Rax, you can't be dying there.
What the hell is it?
Manfan was vaping Bubbly and I can tell him.
It's fine.
I'm healing Bubbly when you walked out of the XQC.
I have a lamp too and the lamp's gone.
I don't want to hear it.
The lamp's gone.
I know, I know, I know.
Oh my god.
There's one, I know, I know.
I'm sucking off my answers.
There's someone on cart.
Don't worry, I got the Jeff for you.
Jeff cut.
Jeff down, major.
Major kill.
Major confirmed.
XQC, you're fine.
Yeah, I killed your Tulpa.
Healing for my friends.
We're thriving.
You got me.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, we are holding down this cart so hard.
That's it.
Don't let anything stay in your way.
Actually, hold all.
I almost have, I almost have all.
I said hold!
Hold!
He's so low, he's so low.
I said just, I'm sure.
How am I dying?
He's so low.
We're peeling.
Oh my god.
Where are you?
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
He's fine.
I'm done, i'm done, I'm done.
You're fine, I'm done, you're fine.
All use.
That's fine.
We're so fine.
Dude, I'm...
Oh my god.
Oh, that's not good.
Any TP's?
Any TP's in chat?
I know.
Are you guys okay over there?
Winnable.
Yeah, winnable.
I'm gonna TP you guys.
Okay, winnable.
BP1.
I have to lap.
I'm healing you.
Guys, if you stay alive a little bit... I have to reload.
Oh, no!
No!
I can't!
I can't get there!
No, no, no.
We have portal.
I can't get there!
I don't...
Oh, a major clutch!
Quick, quick, quick, quick!
I need some help.
Get in, get in!
No!
They all had to go on their main characters to get even close to winning.
That's crazy.
True.
That's pretty... not gonna lie.
That's pretty cringe.
Add four final hits and SVP, blade diff.
So true.
True, true.
More damage.
Unless nowadays, I think we should have triple heal.
Triple heal against flank, I think, is better.
I think we should have held the Groot ult.
Yeah, I agree, I agree.
I think it was Groot ult.
So you're gonna be that guy.
Yeah.
We're having pre... post-game discussion here.
And we can VOD review, guys, if you want to.
Yeah, we can VOD review after.
We should, we should.
Yeah, I agree, I agree.
So, like, next game, we just gotta...
We just gotta ban Black Panther, you know?
Are we gonna play the same map again?
Yeah.
No, they only redo the map if they've lost.
Yeah, that's true.
It won't even let us defend.
Hey, VOD is bad?
Same map again?
Defense?
Oh, Hellfire Gala.
DLS is native.
Hm?
I use...
You use what, Tote?
Uh, I'm looking.
Wait, how do I get to my settings?
I use performance, and I have...
NVIDIA DLSS on auto.
Oh, yeah, actually, he's playing the same map.
Wait, we're playing the same map, guys.
Oh, my f...
There's a why.
Why?
Because I...
Because Poker and I were, like, same map, but swap defense and attack.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Really?
Just play the new map.
TPH.
Wait, there's a...
Oh, my God, I forgot there is a new map.
Like, like...
I'm crying.
We're doing a sponsor from, like, a year ago.
Come on, dude.
It's okay, guys.
We have 20 minutes left.
Oh, wait, isn't there a new team up with Rocket and Starlord?
Yes, there is.
I will willingly play Rocket.
Oh, wait, I got this one.
I got this one.
Wait, unless Fanfan, do you want to play Rocket or no?
Um, hell no.
Okay, I will cut off my hands and play Rocket.
Chat, is the thing any good now?
Yeah, he's okay.
Here's the thing.
Are we actually playing this now?
You can actually...
You can jump to enemies now, XTC.
And punch them out of the air.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can jump to enemies.
You can punch flying characters in the air.
Back shot and then right click.
Gotcha.
The battle starts in 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
You just...
You spent the whole game, right?
Pretty much?
Yeah, and shift when you're low or you need to...
Nice, Poirot.
You got the better, Poirot.
Tiktok.
I know what I need to do after I die.
Wait, another one?
And another one?
I think...
I think he was...
I think he was like, okay, guys.
I'm just gonna jump.
The full reset.
Really, dude?
Strange old as well.
Wait.
Um...
I hear rad.
Moxie.
Yeah, we gotta focus on rad, guys.
You gotta...
You gotta switch characters.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm looking at the new Starlord team up.
Yeah, the new Starlord team up.
That's fine.
You can give it a bit.
Yo.
That's okay.
Oh, my God.
So who's gonna play the new Starlord?
Oh, wow.
Oh, you're so...
You're so dead.
No, I'm coming.
I'm coming.
X is going bladed.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
You're a asshole.
I don't have rest, by the way.
They just lapped.
I hit it, but I did.
Broken character.
You hit.
It looked really cool.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Why is X shooting bladed now?
I killed one off of it.
Okay.
Just watch.
I'm gonna let him cook.
By the way.
I learned a thing or two from him, Wade.
I got this.
Nice.
We're watching.
Guys, can you break this wall?
Can we touch point?
Can we touch?
No, no.
Yeah, I got this.
Oh, I thought it was my F.
It's my E.
He doesn't even know what the build is you.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Just watch.
Oh, we're getting cooked.
I'm Eden.
Oh, someone...
Okay, I believe.
Oh, the draft is one!
What is happening?
There's so many things.
I'm doing it.
I don't know.
I can't do it.
I can't.
I just...
I just cancelled my TP instead of taking it.
Oh my god.
I just...
It's okay.
What?
Why did I get double ootages now?
I will back up.
I think because you're the only...
They're embarrassed from the TP earlier.
Real.
Alright, she too.
Nekros is scary!
Thanks.
He's on Loki.
Yeah.
I know!
That's why he's scary.
I'm actually more scared of Nekros on Loki than any other character.
What?
Okay.
I'll hold first.
Let's go.
We're just gonna break it though.
You have not been tuned into the support grind then.
Okay.
Oh, huge.
Oh, they're low.
They're low.
They lose one.
They can't.
Oh, hell no.
Oh, fuck no.
That's a nice one.
That's unfortunate.
Come back here, you son.
How are we losing this?
I lived hard.
I'm not gonna hold.
Why not?
Wait, wait.
Yeah, do it for sure for it.
Yeah, yeah.
We have three people alive.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, see?
It's fine.
Look, we win the fight.
He pulled out the Wolverine, guys.
Oh, no.
They got me angry.
Oh, you don't want to see him when he's angry.
Oh, yeah.
You don't want...
Just wait.
Wait, what could be your angle or your devil.
Alright.
I'll swap off.
Drop it when I die.
Wait, watch this, watch this.
This is Prime Excusi with right here.
Give me a sec.
Yeah.
Huge.
Was it a big up?
Oh, shit.
It is.
You can't fuck with Thor.
I'll pat you up.
You're walled off.
Don't worry.
I got a...
Oh, I got him.
I got res right here.
They might destroy it.
I mean, they're getting trolled really hard right now.
I wasted all their time.
Alright.
The moment...
The moment Neko swap off support, we know they're locking in.
Did you mind controlling them?
Yeah.
I mean, pretty hard too, yeah.
Or locking out.
Explain how.
Oh my god.
Thor mirror match?
Oh my goodness, bro.
Oh.
Oh no.
How did that grab me?
Holy fuck.
How come I've never seen that combo on our side?
We've done it.
I feel like...
Yeah.
I'm gonna hit it hard like twice.
I feel like I've never seen that before.
It's a hard combo.
It's really hard.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I get it.
It's a really hard combo to hit.
Are these touchable, guys?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
It's 100%.
They're walling the other guys.
I think I'm cooked here.
I am dead here.
It was me or you.
I got one.
We're running this slowly.
Wait guys, I touched point and got their Jeff.
That's pretty good.
I'm gonna throw a bubble before I die.
Wait, don't see nine.
I'm back on the...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got it, you got it, you got it.
Yeah, I got it, I got it.
Now I'm fully unleashed.
Alright, we're locking in now.
Five minute hold, I believe.
Yeah, you wanna try hard?
Let's go full try harder.
Put a bubble for you.
No blade, no blade, no blade man.
Guys.
Wait, uh, Groot's low.
Don't worry, I'm beat, I'm chopping this tree.
Yeah, beat him up.
Nice.
You can ult first.
Bubble, healing bubble.
Oh, they're on hella.
They've been on hella.
I'm gonna fade it.
Oh, big fade.
Oh, nice fade, nice fade.
Guys, I'm in it.
I'm in it.
Oh, um, that's fine.
I'm in the thick of it, everybody knows.
I died, I died through the- Oh, you died through it!
Threw my, my full goop on the ground.
I think you got hit by everything.
It's all good.
I just get bursted.
It's okay, because I have ulti.
Yo, bugger, you say that, we do the combo thing.
Yeah, any second now, I just need to get there.
I'm kinda being, uh, held- I, yeah, there's a character here.
The Jeff, the Jeff is terrorizing me.
Yeah, he's in Zimbabwe right now.
He's in Zimbabwe.
Yeah, we might need to ult.
I believe.
I got a Jeff.
I think he's right here.
Look at that ult!
It's everyone!
Yay!
I want ult too!
I do!
I'm a flying lady!
It's okay.
If I didn't ult, we would have died to Hela.
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They would've relved.
Exactly.
That's smart.
We are stable and we're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can finally defend it.
Wait, what?
He want two ulting lots.
I thought it was boombin.
What?
I think... Are you ulting your turtle?
That clone had it coming.
This guy is ulting his demons.
Wait, there's a turtle behind him.
There's a turtle behind him.
Yeah, it's too much for me.
Oh my... Why can't I... Wait.
He is grounded now.
Maybe I should have saved my...
Oh, that's a big one.
I got my one.
That's good.
That's actually good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry, Moxie.
I'll give you a...
I'll give you a shield.
It doesn't matter what you give me, I'm gonna die.
Don't worry, you'll be fine.
I'll give you a shield.
You'll live forever now.
Can I get a little bit of healing here?
Yeah.
I got it.
Is that inside of?
Oh my god, I didn't know Thor's ult was grounded now.
I thought my fucking game was lagging.
If he uses his E on you, which is like the little dome, and you walk out of it.
Oh, and...
Then you get grounded.
So you have to...
Stay in it.
Yeah, you have to cloak inside of it.
No, but you can still use dash abilities.
It's only for aerial abilities.
No, I can't.
I can't fade.
Yeah, she can't fade.
Oh, fade, yeah.
I'll fade, yeah.
I guess that's an aerial ability.
Yeah.
Cool!
I did not do that.
Okay, now we can get out of this map, right?
We just have to swap sides.
Oh, true, true.
Just swap sides.
Trevor, you didn't really do that much damage in this game.
Sorry.
I mean...
Okay, to be fair, you are 7 and 10.
Mr. Twitch Rivals Champion.
7 and 11?
Twitch Rivals Champion?!
Whoa!
Yep, yep, yep.
Wow!
I love this map, guys.
At a good speed.
Midtown.
It's okay.
There's a good place.
Put in your map, put in your map.
Like, the children's need a new...
No, I can't, I can't, please stop, I can't stop.
Stop, I can't stop, I can't stop.
Come on, ho ho ho ho.
It's okay, we know what to do now, we know what to do.
I can.
If I play this map again, I'm going to lose it.
I should just lose it.
We're getting rage bated.
I don't get it.
We did do two attack shirts for it.
We did one defense.
Oh, that's not even a good draw.
Yeah, real funny.
Are you
gaslighting them?
Yeah.
Wait, we're actually playing...
We're actually playing...
Why are we playing the map again?
I'm going to cry.
We're going to be the party leading.
Can you surrender?
How do you surrender?
We have new characters, new map, new content.
OK, there is no new map.
Okay, there is no new map.
There is no new map, there is not new map.
Can we leave?
Yeah, we can.
We can't surrender in custom lobby.
Yeah, we can't surrender till second half.
No, we can't because it's not a competitive lobby.
It's a quick play lobby.
Yeah, it's a quick play.
We can't surrender in quick play.
We will just leave.
Wait, this character sucks.
Are we actually playing this out?
I mean, Necro's is playing the map over and over again because it's the best flanker map in the game.
And he's just...
You played the last game.
We're getting TikTok ad farm.
Disgusting.
We're going in his YouTube video.
I love being on a YouTube video.
Glad it's the sleepy air.
ZZZZZZ.
Wait, actually I want to play Adam.
Oh, that can kill me.
You're halfway there.
Keep going.
Come on, I'll be on the right side.
There's a flake in tech.
Wait.
Thor.
Dead.
Main.
He's one.
I got him.
Look, guys, we're doing it.
Our fourth time on this map and we're doing it.
Woohoo!
I think it's my LG.
Just saying, just saying.
Do you not want to play this map the fifth time?
Oh, I'd love to, but...
I'm going to go to work on.
Tells me.
How did all of us die?
Uh, they shot and kind of died.
They used gun.
Yeah, they actually did use gun.
Uh, I'm learning it right now.
How did we lose that?
I just got my ult.
Oh, I got him.
Oh, they like double ulted.
Wait, where's our ult?
Oh, I got this.
Guys, I'm going to have 1v5.
You got this.
How the fuck did their blade got up?
Oh, Moxie cooking.
They're not on a jet.
Wait, there's a sleeping Loki behind us.
Door, door, door.
I believe.
Get his ass, get his ass, focus.
There's a Loki behind us, though.
I'm chasing her, bro.
Yay!
I almost went to the game, sorry.
Very nice, very nice.
We can stagger them a little bit.
Stagger, stagger, stagger, stagger.
Loki's still here.
He's still invisible.
I'm going all the way in.
I'm waiting for you, Moxie.
Oh.
Okay, wait, wait, you come out.
You come out, I'll save you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They won't know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stand right here, right here.
He's asleep, he's asleep.
That's good, that's good.
Tech, you didn't expect another invisible Loki.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Are you okay?
No, no, no, no!
I got my ult, I got my ult, I got my ult.
I got my ult.
Whenever you're ready.
I'm ready, whatever.
Why did you run out?
I was trying to get the healing.
Yeah, there was four people in front of me.
I see one.
Thornton!
Nice.
Oh, you!
That's it!
You, General.
Star, Star Lord behind us?
I believe you're four.
Thanks.
I got him.
He's one.
He's dead.
See guys, it only took us four tries to know how to play this map.
There's someone behind us.
I think it's a Loki.
He's been trying to invis blink.
Good, good.
That was a sick 1v1 right there.
You did cheat a little bit.
I healed you.
Let's go ahead.
I'm going to copy.
Massive.
Bring on the chaos.
Nice.
Okay, well, nevermind.
Surefour is just cheating.
I'm on foot.
I'm just...
I'm just pressing the buttons.
He's just clicking heads, you know?
What's going on over there?
Did you copy?
Mostly the body shots, actually.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
I was making a play and then Surefour killed that.
That's a good...
Nice one.
He's walling speed.
Oh!
Holy shit.
He's walling speed up.
It's fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
It's not fine.
He massively healed after the ult.
Alright, escort me out, please.
Um, I...
That's all the seeds I can give.
Yeah, yeah.
All the more leaves, no problem.
I ran out.
I'm a little bit stealing here.
Can you get rid of the snowflake?
Yeah, one second.
Are you eating?
Okay.
Maybe.
She's hungry.
Let me help.
Let a girl eat.
Yeah, you want her to starve?
That's fucked up.
Oh, she ate.
Oh, how many of the others ate?
She's eating.
Oh, you're so dead.
Let's fuck it, let's fuck it.
I've ult in five seconds.
Hold on, the rocket's gonna get assassinated here.
Holy fuck, I almost got one shot.
We can still win this, we can still win this.
I believe.
Four, three, two, one, zero.
I'm waiting for AC to see who...
And then...
Oh wait, I don't have ult yet.
Thanks.
Okay, I'm gonna ult right here, guys.
Let's go.
Nice.
We're in mind, by the way.
He's low, we're in mind, low.
We're in mind, low.
We're behind, low?
Oh, I'm here.
Go, go, go.
Shit.
What the fuck?
What is he doing here?
Very nice.
Okay, that's it.
Last combo we're using here.
Yeah, super combo.
Oh my god, we're finally doing a combo?
Oh, we already did it before this.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I got this.
I'm set up, I'm set up.
Oh my god, we're doing it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, waiting, waiting.
Now.
Are you okay?
I think.
Oh my god, we're doing it again.
Get him, get him, sure, bro.
Wait, me?
You already got him, yeah.
Oh, never mind, that's poker.
It only took us four maps to figure it out.
Oh wow.
Just put me on Blabe.
Yeah, just put me on Loki.
Loki, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Loki on Loki?
Loki goated.
Dude, right on cue.
Beautiful.
Well, that was my LG.
Are you coming for scrims?
Yeah, we have scrims later.
No, I have more.
Are we going to do VOD reviews?
We can do VOD reviews.
Yeah.
Just send me the VOD review.
All right, I got you.
Thank you, guys.
Yeah, GG.
Bye.
Bye, guys.
Nice to see you, guys.
Bye.
Yeah.
Bye bye.
Have a good stream.
Bye.
Bye bye.
For me, for me, that is.
I decided to do Mantis just because I was like, oh, give XQC the team up for it.
I like this new map.
Oh, you mean Midtown?
Yeah, I mean Midtown.
After playing Midtown four times.
Wow, I love the new map.
I had a great time.
I hope you guys had a good time, too.
It was cool to try out all the new team ups and everything.
My opinion.
I think, like...
I mean, Luna's pretty good with her.
That Loki buff is insane, though.
Okay, Loki is actually so fucking good with his new buff and everything.
The fucking Venn diagram that I can make.
I just felt like I was basically, like...
I felt like I could live forever, yeah.
Especially, like, the damage boost and everything with the lamps, too, if I could have that.
Yeah, he was already really broken, because in high elo, they tend to ban Loki first and everything.
So, it is a problem, but Loki is already, like, main priority ban anyway.
But it was fun getting back into Rivals.
I actually haven't played Rivals in, I think, like, a few months now.
I haven't... I haven't played the new season.
I have played a little bit of the new season, but I didn't play a lot.
So, I didn't get a chance to warm up, too, before this sponsor.
But I did enjoy it a lot.
Yeah, a few months.
Yeah, I've been so busy.
I've played, like, here and there, off stream.
Like, maybe, like, one to two games off stream.
But, so I was, like, trying to remember how to aim and stuff while we were playing the game.
But it was really fun with the team.
I really liked the team.
Um, we were obviously all fucking around.
We were all, like, fucking around and, you know, like, moving around everywhere.
And just, like, you know, trolling with our picks and everything.
Uh, so it was really fun.
And then we're doing, like, dumb plans and everything.
Like, the banter was nice.
I liked it.
Uh, I really enjoyed playing with them.
Um, yeah, I got MVP.
I did.
Yeah, our team was definitely not the try-hard team for sure.
We were, our team was the fuck-around team.
We were, we were just fucking around.
Yeah, like, like, Boger is playing Spider-Man.
XQC was playing Blade.
Um, wait, were the, was the other team, like, really quiet?
I was surprised, because they were, they seemed really try-hard.
They seemed, were they actually really quiet?
I thought they were calming a little bit, honestly.
Because, uh, um, they, I thought they were calming, because they were trying so hard.
We were like, what the fuck, why are they on their memes?
They needed the, they need, guys, you don't understand.
Um, they needed the, they needed the YouTube ad revenue, guys.
God, we were, they just wanted to clip farm us.
Uh, yeah, we were the content team.
But it was a fun content.
It was really fun.
Um, um, because the matches we lost were just us fucking around.
And they were still, the matches we lost were just us fucking around.
But it was still super close.
Even though, even though, like, we were fucking around.
So, I thought that was good.
Um, beating XQC and the VTuber.
Beating, beating XOWLPros.
Hello, guys.
I think it was, it might have been a mistake to give the best flanker players midtown, maybe.
Maybe, like, I feel like necros selected the best flanker maps, as in the new cough and midtown, which were both the best flanker maps.
Like, of course he would.
Oh, great.
At least he didn't play Spider-Man.
Because I heard the Spider-Man ult also got buffed, too.
Um, but I had a great time.
Uh, I hope you guys, uh, check out, uh, click on the link, um, that's pinned in my chat.
To check out Marvel Rivals, you can download it now for free.
Um, the newest update comes out on August 8th.
And you can check out Blade and everything, too.
Uh, but yeah, I had a great time.
It was a fun time playing with everyone.
Uh, thank you again to Marvel Rivals for the sponsor.
Um, for the sponsor and for, uh, inviting me to play on this early preview stream.
Um, as always, I'm gonna go head off, because if we do have another stream in two hours.
But, but yeah, it's next week, August 8th, next week.
But, um, what else did I say?
Uh, if you guys are new here, my name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on YouTube, so please check me out on YouTube.
Um, and I tweet out on Twitter whenever I'm live on Twitch.
Um, so yeah, follow me on Twitter.
You wanna know whenever I'm live here.
Uh, if you wanna support me via other means, we have a lot of, uh, merch that's dropped.
As in, there's the knife, the Doki blade, uh, my shop.
Um, and, uh, yeah, I think that's another ways, other ways to support me.
Hey guys, I'm gonna head off now.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture-checked, get up and move around to get that blood flow.
If you, stay up for me, stay up for a little longer, because I'm gonna stream on YouTube.
Or head to bed.
As always, everybody, I'll see you guys next time.
Bye!